Is "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" going
to be ready by its December 2023 release
date? Considering how many times it's
been reshot, we'd certainly hope so.
With the cancellation of "Batgirl," an
uncertain future following the hiring of
James Gunn and Peter Safran as co-heads of
DC Studios, and a yearlong string of bombs
in the record books for 2023, there are only
two more films for fans to look forward to
before Gunn leads a reboot of the universe with
"Superman: Legacy" in 2025. Aside from "Blue
Beetle," which premieres on August 18, there's
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom." And right now,
it's set to be a major Christmas season
tentpole for the studio on December 20.
The production of "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
has been fraught with shakeups, which has
ultimately resulted in three sets of reshoots.
From executive changes to differing expectations
from DC's higher-ups to negative test screenings,
there have been a number of delays that have
resulted in the film's release being pushed back
from December 2022 to December 2023. But a fresh
set of reshoots have the studio optimistic
that things might turn out well after all.
"The tides are changing. Tides are changing!"
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" has
been in the works for so long that
it has managed to survive through three
regime changes at DC Studios. Naturally,
that means each set of execs wanted
different things from the property. The
sequel was greenlit by Toby Emmerich, former
head of the Warner Bros. film department,
while principal shooting was overseen by
Walter Hamada, who served as the head of
DC Films under Emmerich. Both men departed
as the film was undergoing test screenings.
Those test screenings resulted in two sets
of reshoots greenlit by Emmerich and Hamada's
replacements, Michael De Luca and Pamela Abdy,
as well as new Warner Bros. Discovery CEO David
Zaslav. "The Hollywood Reporter" noted that Abdy,
in particular, was hands-on with the sequel and
oversaw a new cut. However, her version did even
worse with test audiences than the Hamada one.
When James Gunn and Peter Safran entered the
picture, a third set of reshoots were greenlit,
which spanned five days — and apparently
pleased all involved. Unsurprisingly, each
set of executives wanted something unique from
the material that each previous cut didn't have.
For instance, Hamada wanted to use
Michael Keaton's version of Bruce
Wayne not just in the second "Aquaman"
film, but across DC's slate of movies
as a sort of guide and leader for
the younger generation of heroes.
"What's the play!? Batman, what do we do!?"
"We try not to die."
Unfortunately, the ever-shifting quicksand
of DC Films resulted in a skewed timeline.
Under the Michael De Luca and Pamela Abdy regime,
reshoots involving Ben Affleck's take on Batman
were filmed to make it more harmonious
with its place in the extended DC world.
However, it appears that none of this material
will make it into the final version of the film,
as James Gunn and Peter Safran didn't
want to build a story promising the
continuation of a universe that's
set to be officially abandoned.
"This world must die."
While that means a lot of the film's
original plot has been changed,
at least those missing moments might
make for fun deleted scenes. But when
you add these internal conflicts to the burden
already shouldered by overworked VFX houses,
you end up with a movie that keeps getting
pushed back from its original debut date.
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" has also
been shaped by repeated sets of test
screenings. Several of these screenings
have resulted in audience displeasure,
with story clarity being an ongoing concern.
This sent the show's producers and executives
back to the drawing board to bring the
best possible "Aquaman" sequel to life.
The end result is several cuts of the film making
their way into the editing process. The magazine
declared that the latest set of reshoots,
greenlit by James Gunn and Peter Safran,
went extremely well. Reportedly, the reshoots
only took four days instead of the five scheduled,
and seem to have finally gelled the film
into what Warner Bros. wants it to be.
There's no word as to what's been
changed in the final cut of the movie,
but at least this winter DC fans will finally
get to find out what all the fuss was about.